yo I need a little waffle with syrup  diggy right here about to spend all  these lyrics get it in pepperoni pizza  if you know me I got a Roby up Sarita  order up a coca-cola then compare own EP  so you know me I'm sleezo and I'm gonna  be at Rita you see me in the bees they  eatin pepperoni pizza oh if I could be  on a rocket ship go up where you take a  lovely trip have lovely relationship  mac and cheese mac and cheese I believe  I could be your mac and cheese mac and  cheese mac and cheese baby let me be  your mac and cheese  let me Mac and you cheese as I'm Mac and  I squeeze your mac and cheese your mac  and cheese  god bless your mac and cheese chips and  guacamole I get it from : I can like you  know me when you don't know me you know  you know home is